[Music]
Coenen I am your biggest fan
are you serious ever in life can I have
a great story for you okay okay so I'm a
silly girl anybody from Philly to just
pretend
[Applause]
so I'm from Philly and I used to take
the train to New York almost every week
to come and see your show live you're
tuning I swear so I used to wait outside
NBC's sorry that's okay that's all good
Ned that does a long time ago and that's
where we did our show yeah yeah so I
used to wait outside and one time I got
here and I brought my friends with me
and obviously doesn't have to meet Conan
like I had this like 2007 I have to be
Conan so Brian McCann they used to open
the show yeah he's a writer who used to
also do the warm-up at the show yeah yes
he used to do the warm-up so my friend
does is like hey yo it's like in the
middle of like him doing the warm-up
she's like yo this is my friend amber
she loves Conan it's her birthday it was
not my birthday and she's like she has
to meet Conan he was like I can tell
you're a big fan okay I'll be right back
so he goes in the back and I'm like I'm
crying like I'm like a Sarah girl and
I'm like oh my god I'm finally gonna
meet Conan and he comes back out and he
walks up to me and he hands me a White
Castle coupon
[Applause]
and what you know what I used to send
your audience and I just say you know
what I'm gonna work so hard and one day
Cohn is gonna interview me and now I'm
here oh that's
[Applause]
I only cried over three celebrities /
Beyonce in you oh that's so nice yeah
for sure
Wow so now we're gonna hang out every
day right White Castle simply right on
the way over here cuz it reminded me of
you and I was just like that
you